it's been 84 years since godzilla vs
kong was first announced
and after months of two second clips
making their way to the internet
we finally have a titan level trailer
that brings the bad boys back to the big
screen
you probably have a lot of questions
such as who are the villains
what exactly is going on and what else
do we know about the movie
well throughout this video we're going
to be breaking it all down and going
over all the easter eggs
things you missed and giving our
theories about what's going to happen in
the film
obviously there will be heavy spoilers
here in regards to some of the story
beats
so if you don't want anything ruined
then i recommend that you turn off now
make sure you smash the thumbs up button
if you enjoyed the video and click
subscribe to never miss a breakdown
without the way thank you for clicking
this my name's paul
now let's get into the trailer godzilla
will come for him
okay so the first thing i think we need
to talk about in this teaser
are the four sides that exist in the
movie primarily there's of course coin
and godzilla
next up is monarch who you of course
know from the previous movie
and lastly are apex the big bad who are
trying to take
everyone down in one fell swoop like
most
versus movies the plot centers around
the group attempting to manipulate the
two towering titans into facing off
against one another
so that they can sweep in and take out
the winner after the loser has softened
them up
i'm not sure that this is a spoiler or
not as the toys were revealed so
long ago that it's probably made it to
your screens in some form or another
but just in case you don't want to know
the big surprise at the end
i've time coded things below if you want
to skip ahead
are you still here good thank you now if
you cast your mind
back to the end of king of the monsters
you'll remember that ikedura head was
shown in the post-credits scene
and according to rumors circulating
around about the movie
its brain is combined with a skeleton
from the 2014 film
in order to make mecha godzilla
apparently the orca device will also
make a return
and this will be implanted inside the
monster's head in order to control the
titans and get them in line
mechagodzilla likely won't be in the
movie all that much
and judging by the character not really
being in the trailers
it's safe to assume that he's being kept
around until the end as a surprise
which we've already ruined now i'm
getting a lot of pacific rim vibes with
this
as in that humanity was attacked by a
giant kaiju
and rather than fighting them from a
ground level they had to level up
and level the playing field there's
levels to these punts
apex themselves are of course playing on
the word apex predator
and they have scoured the globe far and
wide in order to find a way to destroy
the titans once and for all
with this new weapon they want to
finally save humanity
however on the other side of the coin is
monarch who have different ideas
they believe that the titans are
actually a part of earth's ecosystem and
therefore
taking them out will have major
consequences on the rest of the world
this is why they actually journey to
skull island to learn more about the
monsters
and in doing so they uncover all the ins
and outs of the legends
that surround kong and godzilla now it
has long been prophesied that the pair
will face off against each other
and this was told for centuries to the
people of skull island
there are supposedly a bunch of
additional titans here and there
and ones that we've seen in other movies
new ones include nuzuki
who's a giant snake like titan and don't
tell him that i've definitely butchered
his name
because i don't want him to eat me now
the human storyline will revolve around
exploring the hollow earth and learning
more about the titans and the
civilizations that worshipped and feared
them
the gigantic apes and gajira were mortal
enemies
and both kong and godzilla are thought
to be the last of their kind
because the inhabitants of skull island
worship kong as a god
they fashioned a giant axe for him which
has been shown in the toys and trailer
monarch actually discover caverns
beneath skull island that all lead to
the hollow earth
and apparently the titans have all
traveled under these to the plane in
order to fall under the rule of kong
a lot of people have wondered how kong
has actually managed to grow so big
and according to the rumors the hollow
earth had high radiation levels
that seeped into him as he traversed it
this explains why his size has changed
and also why his ancestors on skull
island we're a lot smaller
i think that kong in the film will get
captured by the humans of monarch
and there will be a giant shackle placed
around his neck
you know when a word's on the tip of
your tongue yeah and you can't quite
remember what it is
well that's shackle for me now and i'm
sure it's not called that it's something
else
but never mind i'm wasting your time
just explaining this
now this moment was of course shown in
the two seconds of footage
and it does indeed hint that the humans
have him under control
until he manages to break free now on
the other side of this is godzilla
who now apparently is labeled as the
king of the titans
rather than just being the king of the
monsters everyone's leveling up
hey a terrible joke and there are rumors
that he goes
wild and completely decimates a city
after being put under the control of
mechagodzilla
and this is what we see in the trailer
because of this it disrupts the peace
that kong has lived with since the 70s
and this is also a factor as to why he
wants to fight him
godzilla on the other hand is apparently
anger that the titans have fallen under
his rule
and thus wants to take him out in order
to retain well
order so unlike batman v superman
there's actually a for why both sides
are going head-to-head
and let's just hope that the fight
doesn't end because they realize their
mother's called mothra
sorry i've been doing that joke for
about two years now i just never
expected it to take this song to come
out now
now the pair likely first me at the big
battleship fight
which has been splashed over all kinds
of toys and trailers
this moment looks absolutely incredible
and i love how they're completely aping
pun intended the gigantic navy fleet
this is of course one of the big battles
that we want to see
and i actually think that godzilla will
win this easily
though he takes a punch to the face
that's so hard his entire head
disappears
godzilla is built for the water and
primarily
that's where he's best at even the color
schemes used on the characters so far in
the marketing have always shown him with
a blue tint
whereas kong has an orange one therefore
it's safe to assume that this ties into
godzilla being from the ocean
and kong from the earth on a color
spectrum blue and orange are also
complete opposites
so this hammers home the ideology that
they will be polar to one another
oh look at me analyzing stuff on a
deeper level
now i actually stole that from a comment
on one of my videos and forgot to
screenshot it so i could credit them
so shout out to you and shout out to me
for stealing it
anyway this battle looks amazing and as
i said i think that godzilla will
probably beat kong and then monarch may
help to heal him up in order to have him
ready for the final fight
this is why he seems to be slumped out
on one of the boats and perhaps this is
taking place after it
as he looks like he's had better days
i'm not even sure if he's going to be
their weapon or what but that's just
sort of me joining the dots on the film
either way it makes the most sense to me
that kong loses this fight because of
all the things in this situation
that are against him we can see around
the collar that there are green
canisters
and this might actually be a nod to the
prior movies though this
may be a reach it is possible that this
is berry juice that has been used to
subdue kong in the past
and often it's basically there's a plot
device to put him under control
therefore he's basically fighting
godzilla with his hands and chains
and also gas canisters around his neck
that can easily put him to sleep
as mentioned earlier i feel like he's
being used solely as beta or godzilla
out
and apex may even believe that if they
take out the king of the titans that the
others will fall easier
i think the fight might even escalate
and travel to land
as we see what looks like a camp in
front of a destroyed city
if you look closely you can see what
looks like a monarch logo which likely
means that they are studying the after
effects of it
this may however simply be the aftermath
of the city that godzilla destroyed
and personally i'm probably leaning more
towards that now before the release of
the tv spot i had no idea that rusty
from deadpool 2 was in it
but i'm glad the guy is getting work the
only thing that i'm kind of a bit
mad over is the whole idea where the
kids go off and do their own thing
in order to get to the bottom of what's
going on i know this is a big trouble in
monster movies at this point
but i get a bit bored during these
scenes as the kids are never really in
any danger
and they always make it out without a
scrape just one time i want to see them
get tonlim from lim for disobeying their
wonderful responsible parents
who take them to dangerous and
unchartered islands
now speaking of kids we do see a young
girl offering up a doll to kong
the giant ape himself i've seen a lot of
people wondering about who this is
and there are two ways that it can go
and the first one is that the child is a
native of the island
and that she was discovered by monarch
and taken under their wing
due to the tattoos on her arm and the
fact that she doesn't really say
anything
this could be true perhaps she's
reenacting the original ceremonies that
the inhabitants carried out
but instead of offering up her life
she's now just presenting an idol to him
i hope she gets murdered as well i'm
just kidding i sound like the right
psychopath there so i thought i'd stop
before i said it
however there are clear illusions
between this and the sacrifices that
were carried out in the previous films
hence why i think they're linked i
imagine that we will get a lot of the
backstory of skull island in this film
and this seems like it's doing that to
the best degree possible
now she later appears on the boat kong
as someone that can speak to him
and another theory is that she's
actually the child of eileen chen
and that she's been taken under the wing
of eileen andrews played by rebecca hall
oh come on eileen is that the only name
you can come up with
i got you suckers now perhaps she is
part of the monarch team and found an
idol that is able to summon kong when
she took this to skull island the ape
appeared
and thus monarch were able to capture
him there now from this point we know
that he gets transported across the
ocean
and it seems like the sinister
corporation apex lure godzilla to the
boat
in order to have them fight it out i'm
not a hundred percent sure on that and
at the moment we we don't really know
what side nathan lin
played by alexander skarsgard is working
for so it could be revealed that he is
indeed part of apex
you know how they love the twists in
these movies now it's all clearly
ramping up to this fight at the end
in which we see kong using the axe we
actually see it taking a full blast of
the atomic breath
and the fact it's not completely
destroyed does hint at it being made of
stronger stuff
apparently this is fashioned from one of
the gajira's dorsal fins
and made from a great tree that was
grown by the inhabitants of skull island
as they worship kong they too have been
preparing for this battle
and thus have grown it over millennia to
be used as the handle
should have just got groot instead now
the dorsal fin would be able to
withstand the breath
and that will leave kong with the option
of having it through the majority of the
fight
godzilla only tends to resort to using
his atomic breath when
when he's sort of backed into a corner
as we see with the mines that are
dropping into the ocean
so it does look like kong is actually
going to get some ground on him
now other interesting elements in the
trailer are that kong really seems to be
humanity's weapon against godzilla
ravaging the earth
and there is a big mystery over why
exactly he's doing this
there's a sign that says monarchs
stumped and this could be what drove
them to investigate skull island
kong is clearly seen as humanity's only
hope against the monster
and i absolutely love that they're kind
of putting the sides against each other
in a way
that really makes sense
okay so as a whole i think that the
trailer looks amazing
i'm glad that they're pushing more
towards the battle between the pair
rather than the human drama which is
something that i feel was super
boring in the last two entries let them
fight
is all i want to see people saying and
i'd much rather have that than the
humans making stupid decision
after stupid decision now if the thing
about pacific rim is true
then that makes a lot of sense too as
the franchise
well the first pacific rim was extremely
popular
and it's something that should
definitely be brought across to this
movie
the film has of course had test
screenings already and from what we've
heard
the reactions have been generally
positive and it's been said that the
studio has listened to the criticisms
about the last films
and applied these to make a satisfying
movie that fans will absolutely love
from what i've heard they want to please
longtime godzilla fans
and also make it so that we as audiences
gain a lot more respect for kong
who has been sidelined in recent decades
all in all i just can't believe that
we're finally gonna be seeing this film
and it feels like it's been so long
since the movie was announced until now
i'm hyped but i want to know if you are
too so make sure you comment below and
let me know
all your thoughts and theories on what
we've just seen as a thank you for
interacting with the video you'll be
entered into a prize straw on the 30th
of january in which we're giving away
three copies of the hobbit and lord of
the rings 4k box set to our subscribers
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video make sure
you subscribe with notifications on
and drop a comment below with your
thoughts on the trailer if you want
something else to watch then make sure
you check out our breakdown of one
division
which will be linked on screen right now
we go over all the ins and outs of the
tv show
so give it a watch yeah or else
anyway without the way thank you for
sitting through the video i've been poor
and i see you next time
take care peace